we've got Mark Zuckerberg I love this
story heading to China the Facebook CEO
who knew this visited a university in
Beijing where he has been learning
Mandarin here's Mark Zuckerberg speaking
Chinese okay I didn't understand a word
he said YouTube this one everyone
because this is really great his Chinese
is actually pretty good considering the
fact that he learned it only in 2010 he
proposed in 2012 to his Chinese
girlfriend now wife he had to learn to
speak Chinese to ask for permission from
the woman's mom so but you speak Chinese
no I do not I know how to order a beer
in in Chinese you know well I mean you
know ni right that's what you need to
know to get I can start off that way I
mean his Chinese is pretty good
certainly he looks like he's speaking
Chinese right I mean they they all seem
to respond to that it was a step in the
right direction it was and of course
Facebook though is still banned in China
right you still can't access Facebook in
that country